so habe ich jetzt richtiges xp massaker
alter liegen so viele items runde
oha gebt euch das ist einfach kampf pur
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft hero es ist schon eine
person auf dem server drauf ich habe ein
bisschen angst wer das sein könnte also
ich nehme dann alleine auf ich war
gestern feiern bin deswegen vielleicht
ein bisschen verpeilt gerade ich nehme
gerade auf die folge kommt am 21
am 22 23 also damit nämlich jetzt die
folgen für auf und ab dem 24
1000 folgen zusammen mit der ami nach
einer lange aufnahmesession machen ich
hoffe ich schreibe einfach mal mittels
teil willst du krieg so ich mache mal
kurz meinen texten den scheider
hab nämlich kein burgfriede machen okay
weil ich wollte heute die lange reise
übernehmen und jetzt mal danke an alle
nähe ich auch nicht um ehrlich zu sein
die klage erst mal eine sache das ist
schäbig was kann ich denn alles
reinpacken jetzt sicher nicht so ich
lager nur ganz kurz ich will meine
ganzen tollen kisten sind auch toll ich
kann mir ja so cool jazz machen würde
mir auch oft geschrieben und zwar wollte
ich heute mal auf die suche gehen
reinforced diamond fest dies kann man
davon zweite karriere jeden fall zwei
leben von anderen diamant jemand blog ja
egal wo ich mir dachte ich muss die
sachen auf den fall irgendwo lagern
backpack acht da das haben wir mich die
leute gesagt und zwar soll ich mich mit
dem spiegel
hier zum beispiel hinstellen bei mir in
statt blau
so und jetzt natürlich diesem spiegel
da rein und jetzt kann ich nämlich wenn
ich jetzt irgendwo bin wo blöcke bei mir
sind sprich sager mal hier habe ich mich
ja letztes rheingraben kann ich den
jetzt hier so rausnehmen
so und jetzt teleportiert er mich zu der
stelle wo ich ihn das letzte mal genau
jetzt bin ich im statt blau und jetzt
musste nämlich wieder hier rein packen
also danke an die leute die mir dort
geschrieben haben auf jeden fall richtig
gut kann ich das des white backpack er
übrigens nicht das kann ich übrigens
danke an alle die mir geschrieben haben
du hattest doch noch einen spiegel
spiegel ist einfach mal der spiegel also
ich hab nur richtig geil bogen das euch
übrigens infiniti drauf hat mir gesagt
ich habe hier mal wieder ein paar
gedenkstein gemacht dass mit kaffee ist
fertig schade
nachdem er vater wird fertig werden
irgendwann also endlich infiniti
draufpacken gezeitigt aol fazit halt
hoch aber verzaubert lich kein ding
wieso dieser pilz ihr blut ruhm ich
setze mich einfach mal jeden garten kann
ich gar nicht weiß wo er steht am baum
das cool wir brauchen echt mal so ein
paar bäume hier leute kann man sie
werden immer dran setzen
wenn ich mit denen aufnehme wird
übrigens am 24
also an heiligabend etwas richtig
richtig geiles kommen also ich hoffe ihr
habt ihr bock drauf das wird richtig
richtig geil ich sage jetzt einfach mal
ein paar sachen ich mache mir jetzt
einfach mal so eine diamond chesnais
diamant
diamanten da ich nach element blog so
wie bräuchte es noch reicht bock noch
holz und noch eine kiste
ich habe aber auch so viele kisten
irgendwann ja ich weiss es richtig
richtig richtig viele kisten habe ich
brauche euch dann hab ich überhaupt das
so groß ist holz irgendwo bisschen und
würden die kästchen
ich habe immer nie bock diesen umweg
hitze gehen und auch einen drauf zu
klicken da suche ich dann lieber ein
bisschen ok just jazz fest
ewig bindet vielleicht ja auch hier drin
die 24 kisten muss mir meine kiste hält
bin ich gehöre eigentlich wollte diese
reise machen
ich muss gleich wissen ich merke dass
schon nach 40 tschuldigung tut mir leid
so zeigt mal wieder dass hier geht man
man man man
block zack zack zack kiste so er mir
eine million francs deutschland willst
ich stell dir einfach mal erst mal
hierhin beim pakt ein paar sachen die
ich nicht brauche
us-komiker das nachher immer noch
passieren also den den soll ich
vielleicht mitnehmen weil ich wollte mit
diesem spiel machen
ja ich habe zum endlich feiern okay das
gut es wurde mir gesagt dass ich mir zum
beispiel machen soll bevor ich irgendwo
hingehe
weil ganz einfach das halt
dementsprechend viel einfacher ist wenn
ich dann sehr sehr weit weg laufen und
dann komme ich halt leichter wieder nach
hause
ich mache mir noch ein bisschen hirn
dieser bescheid bisschen wackeln
26 sollten eigentlich irgendwie direkt
ins haus kriegen
okay gut jetzt ist auch wenn ganz links
weg ist wenn mir ganze kohle waters den
brauche ich gar nicht die super g stehen
allen electric darf wollte ich mir noch
welche machen wirtschaftswoche was macht
ihr noch mal electric electric error was
bringt der stadtwerke lag trade die
würde ich dann immer nur mit krieg
nehmen einfach nur dieses darf ich nicht
aus dass ich kann mir noch alter das ist
geil
drei electric stuff das ist gut so wir
müssen in der nächsten folge einfach los
das kws geschaffen die fehler brauche
ich einen fall brauche ich die fackeln
auch ganz neues bei das schild packt ihn
einfach hierhin kommt hoch ich brauche
ich viel gutes zu essen möchte ich auch
richtig viele möhren oder soja leute ich
weiß meine aufgabe ist immer noch luca
macht ihr bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
die stadt so ein bisschen schön aber das
wird alles kommen wenn ich dann
letztendlich mal ich finde diese 20
minuten ich habe so viele sachen vor
immer auch jetzt ich habe etwas
vorgenommen und es ist einfach wartet
hier vielleicht gehören drin und es ist
einfach schon wieder sieben minuten der
folge vergangen als ich komm quasi gar
nicht dazu
irgendwie hat hier bisher bescheid
richtig kommen quasi gar nicht dazu ihn
wahr zu machen weil ich einfach so viele
andere sachen immer hier vor habe ich
mir dann so schon irgendwie programm
gesammelt habe was ich schon so machen
leute wüssten bescheid
beim sie noch immer zu fressen dann
guckt coco loco bereichen essen karotten
fresse ich eben auf
ja komm das müsste reichen mir nie mehr
in tokio mit und dann werden wir jetzt
bogen habe ich die stars solcher
verzaubern
dann werden wir gleich eigentlich so da
kommt jetzt erst mal alles drauf was
geht vom action geht das gar nicht glatt
so auch an breaking the blood afterlife
online verdammt ich hasse das ich nehme
das daraus ich kann mir auch einfach
klicken was neues
und hier auch noch mal so ich nehme
jetzt einfach mal alle mit was ich aber
nicht verstehe wieso kann ich dennoch
meinen rucksack jetzt nicht irgendwie
drauf packen ich kann dir da nicht mehr
rein legen
irgendwie ich weiß nicht warum schreibt
mir mal bitte warum das nicht geht weil
ich dachte man kann alles auf soul täter
verzaubert absolut okay oder soll ich
lieber die triba moment nehmen mit der
habe ich ja auch nachsicht wenn ich dann
auf die haben ja auch ich habe ja wenn
diese 08 15 stall ihr gemacht so wir
laufen jetzt allerdings man in diese
richtung hier
es ist doof mit mit dem links mit die
nachtsicht irgendwie doof hier mit
wir laufen jetzt einfach mal kannst du
über wasser eigentlich kann sie das
schwimmen gut voran die seerose den
spiegel haben wir dabei das eigentlich
relativ gut alles das heißt ich habe
keinen vital
er heißt jetzt egal wir werden jetzt
auch nicht irgendwie kämpfe gehen oder
so möchte einfach nur sexy kahle setzen
für die dings armor
red schon weg gegangen rumpelt helfe
kommt bekommen leute dass das eben ein
neuer pennen gehn ist unnötig gerade was
ich hier wieder abziehen
leider kann ich aber auch bücher
mitnehmen kann ich mir die trivago
anziehen und damit das ganz gut
also das soll jetzt auch nicht jetzt
irgendwie so werden so wenn ich jetzt
tue sie dann kann ich vielleicht mal
reingehen so gucken was da so drin ist
aber nein also ich will jetzt nicht
irgendwie losziehen um zu kämpfen
dann werde ich dann vielleicht mit denen
machen oder keine ahnung was uns da mit
24 erwartet
wer weiß wie könnte man den kommentar
schreiben was ihr denkt was am 24 kommt
mit denen das wäre interessant hier
versenkt so wartet über hier so kann ich
nicht eigentlich was das habe ich etwas
habe ich noch nie gemacht was sind dass
ihr für sachen die ich habe keine ahnung
ich kann auch einfach mal beide hre
das bringt ja gar halt nur noch da gut
stellbrink dass da nichts dann haben
auch ein bisschen böse leben für dich
schätzchen
so 64 superreichen und jetzt ziehen wir
im jahr kommen wir gehen in diese
richtung ich hab kein bock nicht wasser
achten wollen wir auch noch und ab um
die kurve zur kurzweiligen und dann
wären wir schon längst weg
dann werden wir jetzt mal auf die suche
gehen
existenzen aber ich glaube eben diese
richtung bin ich schon sehr sehr häufig
gegangen oder ich glaube das ist die
richtung in die ich bisher am meisten
gegangen bin
ihr müsst einfach gucken was er dann so
auf und stößt dabei könnte ich jetzt
eigentlich über ein thema reden weil ich
habe gesagt über diese für diese reise
brauchen wir eine menge themen die und
mir ihr mir schreiben könnt und da kamen
echt richtig richtig gute sache noch ein
paar sachen wo wir ein bisschen mehr
darüber nachdenken muss und zwar erstmal
also so ganz normal so sachen die auf
jeden fall jeden interessiert haben so
youtube datenschutzrichtlinien kacke im
moment da weil youtube zurzeit relativ
viel kacke baut meine nase läuft habe
ich ein taschentuch ich habe ein
taschentuch
ich brauche jetzt einfach mal so ganz
will ich meine nase mitten in der folge
also was ihr seht aber die so ein tolles
panorama eltern sieht auch geil aussehen
wie ich gucken dass ich meine nase
moment das land youtube macht ja zurzeit
kacke die machen ja alles hier was nicht
irgendwie bei drei auf dem baum sitzt
zeigen die irgendwie an wegen angeblich
urheberrechtsklage auch bei liedern oder
so von denen ich die kompletten lizenzen
habe sagen die mir du hast nicht die
lizenzen du bist kacke
so nach dem motto halt
verstehe ich nicht was sie damit
bewirken wollen weil sie damit ihre
eigene video sperren mehr oder weniger
und auch wenn das ist so unnötig weil
ich einfach die ganzen lizenzen habe und
ich habe sogar dass sie das beste in
einem video habe ich gar keine musik
verwendet streit darauf von ihm zum soll
von von sony music
irgendwas dingsbums mit den streik
bekomme ich so ok in als strike beste
ach guck mal hier war ich doch schon
vielleicht doch schon mit denen überall
müssen jetzt eigentlich brauche ich mir
wirklich ich muss mir eigentlich die
fifa vor seiner reise machen aber ich
muss die reise gerade machen
ich bereue es richtig dass mir diese
baglama als erstes gemacht habe dies so
packe ich mag die überhaupt nicht kenne
auch keinen der die anders cale und tief
ist das beste einfach naja jedenfalls
weiß ich echt nicht was das soll vor
allem auch an anderen videos wo ich dann
einen song benutzer von der sogar eine
beschreibung dann steht da ja hefti
commission und youtube einfach so hast
du mich so sei es ihr gutgeht shawky mit
seinem co2 das ist echt sein
das ist heftig heftiger alptraum diese
das rennen hat alles so langsam
ich glaube ich einfach mal ganz kurz
stehen und führt da jemand schock über
das die welt sich ein bisschen aufbauen
kann
jetzt gibt er mich wieder so hier müssen
wir langsam hierzu ein paar sequenzen
wie viele bräute eigentlich auch schon
welche ich habe aber auch von gar keinem
bisher irgend etwas geschenkt bekommen
ich sehe immer so bei anderen so kriegen
sie dann von siebenthal diamond oder den
er bekommt einfach mal tausende von steh
ich suche mir alles selbst jessica
lizenz juhu ich muss hier alles wieder
selbst suchen der luca der selbständig
gemacht dass alleine
ich weiß echt ich glaube ich wird den
weg in friedberg frösche steht aber das
sieht schöner aus
das ist echt so wie im urlaub weilt hier
gerade das ist megaschön kann einfach
mal ein vorteil gemacht wir sicher bei
16 minuten mann mann mann mann dann wird
blut gehabt hat wie es allgemein grad
sagt dass ein bär
man ist hier denn nicht irgendwo lexika
alles sein wissen auch die leute wenn
wir hier schon drin sind wenn wir schon
so ein ding übersehen sehen wir bestimmt
dass das schon ausgeräumt wurde oder
doch nicht
nice alter
so ich hoffe man so ein paar essenzen
für mich
hab jetzt durch ihr blöd denn nun ist
noch einer die mögen mich irgendwie alle
gar nicht verwunderlich denn noch so
nett zu den hier lopez adam tablet pc
optimal verbiss durch verbiss durch
ich hab keine angst ich habe immer angst
du dann habe ich nur noch eine halbe
leben voll
ich muss meine rüstung auch auf jeden
fall mal verzaubert ich habe bisher nur
an breaking drauf muss aber irgendwas
geiles draufpacken irgendwie so coole
sachen verzauberung oder auch einfach
vielleicht mal bessere waffen ich habe
nur diesen regenbogen dies little giants
wort von dem dann alle meinen das ist ja
doch eigentlich gar nicht sogar sei aber
womit ich einfach mal diener geklatscht
hat das verstehe ich auch nicht
hallo und treffer
dass man besser damals wären heftig
waren mittlerweile so walter von wo
schießt denn da einer jeder nummer hier
ist richtiges massaker alter was geil
wäre mit wieder so ein paar geile sachen
haben die präsenzen gedruckt sind das
wichtigste fest oder auch mal so normale
herzen so fallen lassen
die haben gar keine lizenzen dachte ich
werde das jetzt auch mal so umstellen
eben bei welcher weg fliegen will nicht
ein letztes mal anderen electric darf
nicht dass er dann irgendwie kaputt geht
ständig fliegen will
elektriker sense kubica da glaube ich
gleich drei doppel steigt dort aber
steigt in meinem kopf drin so da sind
oha da sind wieder so viele jetzt aber
ich glaube jetzt alle erst mal raus
und jetzt schießen sie mich ab das ist
kenne man schießt ihn ab und der blockt
einfach die pfeile kommt zurück weil das
ist eine geile sache hier ne da kriegt
man so viel geld richtig gut
bock hat die fan das dsl-geschäft ort so
hat hier noch in der elektrik essence
tropfen lassen bleibt dabei auch gut
hallo ist da man das sind so die
leichtesten ich kann jetzt eigentlich
gar nicht persönlich bin ja gerade im
kampf theoretisch genommen ich über
ziehe jetzt mal ganz kurz weil ich
möchte dass die erst kurz fertig machen
bevor ich jetzt irgendwie stoffe und
dann stehe ich ihnen wieder fordern so
war diese beeren mit trotzdem angst
ich habe echt aber so diese horror
vision dass auf einmal einen teil von
meiner rüstung kaputt geht und ich quasi
so was von anfällig bei elektriker
setzen und zwei electric ge setzten
wie viele davon sind
oha schickt dich nicht abtreten
herr uwe schief beim bogen auf einmal so
schnell irgendwie mit verzögerung auf
das er so mega schnell ist oder hobbys
durch verpisst euch hell da kann ja was
nicht stimmen als ob er so schnell
schießt wo habe ich als richtiges xp
massaker alter liegen so viele items
runde
gebt euch das ist einfach kampf pur
einfach hatte tut so ein richtiges
massaker hier bling bling bling bling
bling bling bling bling bling bling
bling bling übrigen auch immer einige
leute sollen
luca warum hast du denn vom von walking
bus blabla ab der so geile items da
hinten drin und so und ja also wenn er
mich so heftig kaputt boxt dieser typ
dann hat man das schon mal ein bisschen
angst genauso wie wenn da halt auch wenn
sie nicht gut sind wenn richtig viele
gegner kommen habe ich grundsätzlich
immer angst das war eigentlich ganz gut
weil das ist ein defensives verhalten
dass man sich so retten möchte und so
alle der einer dahin hatten diamant
schwert der bar brunner
ähnliche treffen so hier liegen jetzt
ein paar schöne sachen so und danach
musste ich jetzt erstmal kurz stoppen
die folge ich bin voll ja ich bin voll
ich muss das einfach jetzt in diesen
rucksack ich weiß jetzt einfach mal ein
paar sachen weg hier so was sieht hier
noch so rum
erfahrung ist hier gar nichts mehr
ja ich habe ein bisschen angst dieser
verdammte ding da oben das machen wir in
der nächsten folge der nächsten folge
gehen wir da mal hoch und dann würde ich
erst mal sagen leute wenn euch diese
reise bisher gefallen hat wäre jetzt
bisher eine existenz aber wenn man auf
jeden fall electric essenzen gesammelt
wir haben war richtig geilen abenteuer
bisher wieder erlebt jetzt werde ich
oben noch gleich eben rum lauf und noch
ein paar sachen klatschen hier wenn sie
ja ja wenn es euch bisher gefallen hat
dann will ich mich definitiv über eine
positive bewertung freuen
das echt wichtig dass sie die videos
bewertet wie es euch gefällt es wenn es
aber wirklich sagt immer wenn es euch
gefallen hat mir wird jetzt positiv
jetzt nicht gefallen hat dann negativ
oder kritik oder wie es wollte und dann
würde ich sagen da hinten sitzen wieder
so leute und wir sehen uns dann in der
nächsten folge wieder ruhig dahin wir
hingehen werde